let's look at a big time woke short
circuit right-wing author Bethany Mandel
who actually wrote a book about wokeness
was asked what is woke and she visibly
short circuits the interviewer is
Brianna Joy gray who recently attacked
me but yet I am still praising her for
asking this basic question because it is
a question that should be asked it's
almost I mean quite frankly it's one of
these things where it's like who's the
president right now we use it as a
sanity check for a lot of right Wingers
what do you mean by woke it's such an
off some are calling it a gotcha but
it's not a gotcha in that it's so
obvious and if you're going to talk
about wokism and if you're going to
attack wokism and and talk about all of
the reasons why wokism is bad you should
be prepared to explain what it is and
here is Bethany Mandel
asked about her book stolen youth how
radicals are erasing innocence and
indoctrinating a generation sounds very
scary and it's scary because of woke
what is woke well let's see if she can
explain it you might be surprised by
what she does or maybe better said
doesn't say far left only seven percent
of Americans consider themselves very
liberal and probably fewer of them
consider themselves to be woke and so
you know when when we're talking Angela
would you mind the finding well because
it's come up a couple times and I just
want to make sure we're on the same page
so
I mean woke is sort of the idea that
um
I
this is going to be one of those moments
that goes viral I mean well yes but for
a different reason than she thinks is
something that's very hard to Define and
we've spent an entire chapter defining
it no it is sort of guys you've got to
read a whole chapter to understand what
it is the understanding that we need to
re totally reimagine and re reduce
Society in order to create hierarchies
of Oppression uh
to create hierarchies of Oppression what
are you talking about Bethany
sorry I
it's hard to explain in a 15 second
sound bite yeah
it's one of those things that uh I mean
everybody is weighing in in okay so this
other dude basically saved sir
this is really really wild I mean that
is a short circuiting like I have never
seen in a very long time in this sort of
context so a couple different things
anybody can lose their train of thought
truly this isn't about it's you know if
somebody said to you hey when you say an
apple what exactly do you mean and you
might stumble because they might be like
well you know I mean a round fruit
that's green oh like a lime well no it's
it's a round fruit from an apple tree
that oh but yeah but you can't say from
an apple tree to Define it like you
could you could have difficulty with
definitions in this way and you can also
lose your train of thought
but the critical part when it comes to
woke is as I've been explaining to you
for a long time it used to mean one
thing its meaning was perverted by the
right but many of those who attack
wokism don't actually understand what it
is and that Mushmouth confetti word
salad whatever it was doesn't get us any
closer so let me make it like abundantly
clear to people what we're talking about
the original meaning of woke before
Republicans perverted it and we've we've
done a segment on this but it should be
included here what it first meant before
being perverted by the right
the term woke simply meant
I've become aware
of causes of social justice that I can
support through activism that's all it
means oh I learned about the fact that
uh uh public transit can be used in a
discriminatory way I've become woke to
that now I understand that that's an
issue maybe I want to do something about
it that's what woke initially meant we
might challenge a status quo or we might
fight some kind of Oppression and it's
all to create a better world that's what
it meant okay now Republicans when they
say woke
it it's a shorthand for any idea or
policy I don't like that's on the left
okay that's one version of it or also
it's a sort of conversation stopper the
same way that sometimes people say
that's offensive oh but that's woke
nonsense that's fundamentally what it is
now where Bethany Mandel gets into a
into a problem here is that she wants to
define it
as the horrible negative thing that the
right wants to make wokeness out to be
and her physical struggle I mean she's
having a physical struggle to actually
spit it out
comes from the fact that it's not what
they claim it to be what the right wants
to claim wokeness to be is some kind of
unfair
non-evidence-based capricious
far left
socialistic or communistic attempt to
completely restructure the fundamentals
of society in some kind of outrageous
Marxist worldview you know some some
combination of that and it sounds crazy
when you say it and so Bethany Mandel is
right it's hard to distill her entire
insane chapter about woke into a 15
second sound bite but it's hard because
their view of what wokeness is is a
Fantasyland imaginary piece of nonsense
so super interesting super interesting
and I know you know the the framing is
oh everybody's gonna make fun of her
because she stumbled no The Stumbling on
this particular issue is representative
of the way that the right has perverted
wokeness but also doesn't even really
explain that perversion
in an even remotely coherent way that's
what we saw here and uh it is absolutely
fascinating to see and remember check
out my segments two two important
segments on this number one the Bill
Maher segment where he's asked to Define
woke
and number two my segment they don't
even know what woke means those two
segments combined with this one tell us
80 to 90 percent of what we need to know
about the rights use of this term hey
this is very very interesting we're
continuing to cover
the soft about face happening on Fox
news with regard to the failed former
president Donald Trump's new candidacy
in 2024 and Fox and Friends host Brian
kilmead is really at the center of a lot
of this and what is taking place you
know sometimes there's this feeling in
when you do what I do
that we have to explain a phenomenon in
the absolute most extreme black and
white terms fox has completely abandoned
Trump and is now hostile to him and will
do anything they can to prevent him from
being president no that's not what
happened what is happening on Fox is
that a number of hosts Brian Kilmeade is
certainly one of them have done a soft
turn away from Trump where it seems
pretty clear that even if it's not about
personally what they want but as they're
as their the role that they play on
their Channel dictates they want to be
friendly to the idea of a DeSantis a
candidacy and presidency if it doesn't
happen they're not going to completely
cut Trump off such that they have no
access to him if Trump really is going
to be president for another four years
Fox would be very poorly positioned uh
if they lost access to Trump because of
you know adversarial or antagonistic
relationships on the the other hand
they do want to be there
if indeed someone else takes control of
the Republican party and ultimately the
presidency like Ron DeSantis but and so
we've seen Brian kill me do a number of
different things go out on the street
and try to find DeSantis supporters or
play catch with Ron DeSantis in a total
softball interview as we looked at
yesterday this sort of thing
here is something that actually did
surprise me a little bit which is that
Brian Kilmeade brings up
Trump now seems more disciplined than he
did at one point like for example
compared to when he had lunch with white
supremacists it is genuinely surprising
to me that Brian Kilmeade is even
willing to acknowledge that take a look
at this segment since he went and
visited East Palestine uh stopped having
lunch with white supremacists and has
got a very disciplined message according
to the Emerson poll he's got 73 percent
uh approval rating among Republicans
with high school with high school
degrees or below and he's winning in
almost every state outside California
and I'll add this to it it would be
interesting if he does not win Iowa and
you go to and and Governor sununu gets
into New Hampshire and Governor soon is
so popular winning three terms as
Governor there he could be out and on a
bit of a roll this is the most
discipline I've ever seen him even
compared to 2016. if you see his team
you get text messages every day okay so
he said this is the most disciplined
I've seen Trump since he stopped having
lunch with white supremacists or as
Brian Kilmeade calls them supremists
which is a different word but I totally
understand what Brian Kilmeade means
this is the Trump pivot
that remember is a conditional pivot
it's a tentative pivot it's a sort of
depending on what happens pivot we'd
kind of rather someone other than Trump
be the nominee but if it is Trump we
can't totally abandon him because we're
going to want access for the next four
years now this is quite a low Bar for a
presidential candidate right it's an
understatement to call this a low bar
Trump has never seemed this disciplined
uh particularly since he stopped having
lunches with white supremacists the you
know the mainstream media won't tell you
but guys it's been months since Trump
lasted dined with white supremacist and
we've got to give them credit for that
it is a stunningly low bar but it is a
little bit surprising to a degree that
Brian kilmead is even talking about the
white supremacist lunch and it does seem
like another one of those subtle digs
we'd rather someone else but I'm also
framing this as a positive thing we'd
rather someone else but Trump is looking
pretty damn disciplined at this point in
time
super interesting and fox of course
wants to host Republican primary debates
when they get going never mind
presidential debates and so to some
degree they have to do this now if we
look at the latest polling what does the
polling say about what's going on it's
really a mixed bag there's a new morning
consult poll rated B minus where Trump
is winning over DeSantis by 24. that's a
poll that includes a ton of other people
including Pence and Haley and Liz Cheney
and Abbott and a whole bunch of
different people there's a new CNN SSRS
poll not as well rated of a poll that
one's a c plus c plus B minus is pretty
similar that one has DeSantis ahead of
trump even with the inclusion of Nikki
Haley and Mike Pence and Tim Scott and a
bunch of other people these are two
polls conducted essentially at the same
time by very similarly ranked pollsters
with a 26 Point difference Trump plus 24
versus DeSantis Plus 2.
uh very very interesting but it cannot
be ignored that the vast majority of
these polls public policy polling
premise University of North Florida is
an exception and that's looking
specifically at Florida but in the
National polling Trump's winning most of
them even with this outlier CNN poll so
Fox News is doing what Fox News is most
uh inclined to do how do we maintain
access for future profitability and
ratings that is at the end of the day
the number one priority that explains
Fox hosts caught in text messages
acknowledging that all of the election
lies were indeed lies but saying our
viewers believe something else and so
we've got to keep going with that
narrative on TV expect this to continue
and it is really wacky stuff that Brian
kilmead clip will be on my YouTube
channel which you can find at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
and a Spanish version of this very story
will be on the Spanish YouTube channel
which you can find at davidpackman.com
Spanish one of our sponsors today is Bon
charge I have always enjoyed dry saunas
you get in there your heart rate is up
dilates the blood vessels can soothe
achy joints and muscles it's relaxing
it's just a great way to remove a little
stress Bon charge is the creator of the
infrared sauna blanket which you can
enjoy from home super easy to set up
heats up fast you don't have to have
your head inside like at a traditional
sauna at the gym nice for meditating or
reading getting work done relaxing I
have found it to be a great way to
unwind at the end of a long day easy to
clean Sleek lightweight design easy to
store and comes with a 12 month warranty
and of course if you don't love it
returns are super easy but I think you
will love it go to boncharge.com
and use the code Pacman 15 for 15 off
the link is down below
the David packman show continues to be
supported directly by our viewers and
listeners I invite you to become a
member at joinpakman.com it's very quick
it's very easy you get some great
benefits including an extra show called
the bonus show every single day as well
as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show get all of it by
signing up at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code 24 starts now to save
that's a discount code all of it
happening at joinpackman.com Donald
Trump's defense lawyer or one of them
went on MSNBC and lunged at the host Ari
melber to try to rip some papers out of
his hands I have never seen anything
like this it is a complete and total
meltdown by attorney Joe takapina
probably not the best idea to go on
MSNBC to begin with and it went just
about as badly as you can imagine the
subject matter was of course the
continued Stormy Daniels controversy now
we are years into this controversy Joe
takapina saying Trump didn't really lie
when he said he didn't know anything
about it because uh he would have
violated the terms of the settlement and
so it's not really a lie take a look at
this and about a minute in he's going to
Lunge for Ari melber in a completely
unhinged moment for anybody particularly
for a defense lawyer
if all of what you say is true it is
then why was Trump hiding it and lying
about it at the time and I'll play that
for your response he lied about it we
all know that take a look let's see
the question was did you know about the
payment to Stormy Daniels and Trump says
no now we we all know Trump did know
about it but that's the the sort of the
core of this
[Music]
hey that's what you're going to consider
a lie a lie to me is something material
under oath in a procedure I didn't say
perjury I said a lot yeah but that's not
a lie that's that's not a lie here's why
it's not a lie that's not a lie here's
why it's not alive could you did you
know about this okay so now he's lunging
for the paperwork he's lunging for Ari
yeah because it was a confidential
settlement so if he acknowledged that he
would be violating the confidential
settlement she doesn't make it not a lie
it could make it a legal problem but
that doesn't make it not a lie is it the
truth of course it's not the truth it's
of course not the truth but it is not a
lie they say the left are the
post-moderns where words have no meaning
anymore post-filled truth she would be
in violation of the agreement if he told
the truth so by him doing that by him
doing that he had it was abiding buy not
only his rights but Stormy Daniels it
seems like we're drawing some blood here
because you're having a strong reaction
yeah strong reaction is an
understatement did lie about it and in a
confidential settlement you can easily
say no comment or I'm not getting into
it he says and the reason why I look at
this he says no no I didn't know about
it he did know about it didn't he you
know but here's the thing I don't know
the timing of that video I really don't
and I'm not trying to ah so now we have
a new argument maybe at the time Trump
really didn't know about it really Joe
April 28th but I don't know the timing
of that video in relation to the timing
of the other video where he was speaking
to microphone what was the date of that
other video do you know uh yeah we have
the Cohen recording this was around the
2016 campaign pre-november right it was
2018 later uh the original conversations
were in the uh fall of 2016. yes sir so
obviously he knew about it but what he
decided to do was not violate the
confidentiality so once pressed where
listen the dates aren't going to get you
out of this Joe now he says well listen
Okay the dates do suggest he knew about
it but he was not acknowledging it in
order to stay compliant with the
confidentiality agreement clause and
provision of that agreement which was
the right thing to do so yeah he could
have said no he didn't lie and lying was
the right thing to do oh great I hope
that this comes to court at some point
as an explanation
or he could have said I don't know
anything about it which is what he did
but that's the right I would advise my
client to do the same thing he's
speaking to some whether it's a
journalist or some young lady September
2016 is the exact date but but whether
he's speaking to a a journalist or some
young lady on the street just shouting
out a question that is not the form for
him to go into detailed question about a
confidential settlement agreement right
so guys he didn't lie and he was
completely correct to lie based on the
circumstances and because it might have
been a young lady shouting at him on the
street this is the sort of legal
representation I guess that you find
when uh I don't know you you look at the
back pages of a classified newspaper or
something
this guy is actually relatively well
known Joe takapina and I know that is I
know he's come up on the show before
although I don't remember the exact
context
this is ridiculous this is and if this
is the type of argument that Trump's
council is going to be making if and
when
indictments do come forward and I'm not
saying they will I'm not but at this
point it's like either they will or they
won't but if they do
if this is the sort of uh legal counsel
that Trump is going to be surrounding
himself with
it doesn't look very good now it is
important to mention that Donald Trump
has a history of having sort of like
your TV lawyers and then your actual
lawyers and the TV lawyers go on TV and
they say certain things and your actual
lawyers that are working on cases are
usually different where we saw this come
to a disastrous head was with Alina Haba
I believe her name was where she was
both talking about Trump as a lawyer on
TV but also filed some motions and very
quickly got herself into hot water after
the search warrant was served at
Mar-A-Lago where if I again I'm going
for memory if I recall correctly she put
her name on something saying they gave
back all the documents even though they
clearly hadn't and it became a very very
quick mess so the point here is Trump
has TV lawyers and real lawyers I don't
know that he pays either of them quite
frankly
but if this is the sort of
representation we expect them to have
it's going to be really really wild if
he does get himself indicted I know I
know I know that you're not going to
believe this but a trump endorsed Maga
candidate who lost
is saying she's having trouble
flushing her toilet and getting it to
properly flush
with only one pull of the chain for lack
of a better term
I if I told you that this was going to
be a topic a few years ago
Trump obsessed with toilets and people
he endorses obsessed with toilets I
wouldn't have believed it and I wouldn't
have expected you to believe it but in a
segment on Fox News Leo Terrell and
Tudor Dixon are on remember Tudor Dixon
was the failed magacan that it Trump
endorsed who ran for governor in
Michigan
massive dumps of votes came in for her
opponent Gretchen Whitmer and Tudor
unfortunately for her did not become the
governor of Michigan but no need to
worry she still is weighing in on the uh
important political issues of our time
and those include
stoves Hannity is upset that they're
coming for his stove soon
and tutor isn't pleased with her toilet
this is considered political commentary
in 2023 listen to this well um Michigan
gubernatorial candidate Tudor Dixon
tutor I'll throw this to you first first
they want my stove now they want my
dishwasher what's next they're going to
take away my iron next I don't know
yeah well look I'm someone who does lots
of laundry I do laundry for six people
every week and so I know a little bit
about this and the last thing I need is
my laundry taking longer I'm already
dealing with a low flow shower head and
my kids are coming out with conditioner
smashed to their head like an old
Seinfeld episode and I have to tell them
to get back in and re-wash I can't even
flush my toilet one time to get toilet
paper down because of the low flow
toilets I don't need a low flow washing
machine folks this is more a segment for
a dietitian or nutritionist tutor is
missing some Fiber in her diet this
isn't about low flow low flow toilets
whose regulations have not actually
changed for a very long time how on
Earth did Republicans get obsessed with
toilets and remember this all goes back
why do right Wingers have so many
Plumbing issues you know with left-wing
people I know
no one ever seems to have an issue with
plumbing Plumbing's working beautifully
uh I'm actually having some Plumbing
work done soon I'm gonna I'm gonna ask
about this I'm going to ask my plumber
do Republicans struggle with toilets
more than Democrats here is the origin
of this when Donald Trump first said
he's got a flush his toilet 10 to 15
times we have a situation where we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
and other elements of bathrooms yeah
where uh you turn the faucet on in areas
where there's tremendous amounts of
water where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it yeah
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out they're stripping out very
quiet quietly have you ever seen when
you take a shower the water drips out
very quietly yeah people are flushing
toilets 10 times 15 times as opposed to
one it's just
today as it was however many years ago
this guy is out of his mind huh they end
up using more water
so EPA is looking at that very strongly
strong you go into a new building or a
new house or a new home and they have
standards on where you don't get water
you can't you can't wash your hands
practically there's so little water
company you can't wash your hands so
let's add some reality to this I think
that for most of these people I mean we
know about Trump's diet I don't know
what Tudor is eating but we could take
some guesses
um this is really an issue of diet and
it's not actually an issue of plumbing
and sometimes it can be confusing but
it's really a diet issue to add reality
about the regulations what they are
talking about when it comes to the
shower heads is that the energy
Department under Biden decided to go
back to the standard from 2013. okay
about shower heads now the truth is it's
not really going to make a difference
Trump made a small modification that
allowed for slightly higher flow shower
heads based on how water per minute is
measured where instead of being per your
total shower it could be per device so
if you have like a rain shower head and
then a handheld you could have a total
of 2.5 gallons per I'm sorry you could
have 2.5 gallons per minute for each
each element
whereas the previous rules were 2.5
gallons per minute total so it's
basically going to change nothing what
Biden did because just about every
shower head on the market meets the 2013
requirements it's not like Trump changed
this and then all of a sudden every
manufacturer changes what they're doing
and then now they're going to have to
change it back and everybody who
installed is gonna have to it this is
just it's a made-up issue quite frankly
okay
the toilet stuff is even dumber because
there's nothing going on with that other
than I mean listen we know Trump was
trying to flush documents down the
toilet that might have been a factor in
the trouble he was having but this is
wacky wacky stuff and where we are now
is that Republicans go on Fox News and
complain one flush just isn't doing it
for me I don't know about you Sean
today I'm going to be speaking with
Professor Alastair Smith who teaches
politics at New York University and is
also co-author of the book The
dictator's handbook why bad behavior is
almost always good politics I really
appreciate your time uh great to have
you on today
very glad to be here
so let's start with this this premise
that bad behavior is good politics
because it seems maybe to to the
layperson that sometimes bad behavior is
actually bad politics but it seems that
may be more internationally and less So
within the country wherein that is
taking place so is it important to
distinguish when we say bad behavior is
good politics whether we're talking
about International reaction or within a
Leader's country or does it does it not
matter does the principle hold true
regardless
well I think we should stop worrying
about what's good or bad we should worry
about what leaders choose to do and what
leaders to do is what's good for them I
want to emphasize them as the particular
individual and not the country so the
president United States does what is
good for the president United States Kim
Jong-un does what is good for Kim
Jong-un and that typically means keeping
those people happy that you need to stay
in power the difference between why we
get much better governance in the United
States is because the U.S president
needs the support of tens of millions of
people and Kim Jong-un needs the support
of tens or hundreds but certainly no
more than thousands of people and it's
that scale of how do you keep a lot the
the appropriate people happy determines
the kinds of policies that leaders have
that's interesting so in the United
States the good politics are that which
will get you re-elected in the system we
have which includes a hundred plus
million people voting obviously with the
influence of lobbies and corporations
and all of these other things in North
Korea similarly the good politics that
keep you in power are those immediately
sort of around you who could try to
depose you but it is less about the
population of North Korea
right you should never make the mistake
of thinking leaders are out there to
make life good for the people and so the
US I don't think of the us as behaving
in a very particularly normatively good
way with respect to overseas politics
which is I think where you where you
started this conversation is because the
U.S president is not beholden to the
people in other countries
so the U at the president's job is to
enrich and improve the welfare of the
people that he needs to stay in power
and we shouldn't expect him to do
anything else so foreign aid military
intervention is designed for promoting
the interests of the people the
president cares about and not the
interests of the countries where AID is
being delivered or intervention is
taking place if we look at a situation
like Russia which is being sanctioned
heavily because of its incursion into
Ukraine
um there was an interesting NPR piece I
heard about a week ago which argued that
despite whatever is being publicly said
about the very limited impact of the
sanctions the sanctions are actually
really disastrous for Russia at all
levels I guess we don't know
definitively whether that's true or not
but let's let's imagine that it is the
case that the sanctions are having a
disastrous impact how does that change
or impact this balance of what is good
to stay in power when you introduce an
external Force like a sanction
well you know again why sanctions I
always think of whenever sanctions are
applied they've almost always failed
before they start if if the sanction was
going to be a big enough stick that it
was going to get compliance
that the leader in the in the Target
state would have already complied with
the threat so the fact that they're
being applied means that they're almost
certainly not going to work
and The Wider they get applied it's
because it's domestically popular for
Western Europe and North America to
apply these sanctions so it's good for
the president to do it keeping the
constituents happy it pro it may
actually be very helpful in Russia uh
what one of the crisis one of the
consequences the price of oil is higher
so there's more Revenue also the fact
that there's now limited options for the
oligarchs or um to trade and enrich
themselves in any other way all the
revenue all the wealth all the benefits
that are coming politically now come
centrally through Putin because the
sanctions have limited the access and so
in some sense it's given Putin a little
bit more power this is our problem with
sanctions you know uh in when the U.S
sanctioned Iraq against Saddam Hussein
one of the consequences was that the the
value of smuggling became much more
valuable who controlled the smuggling
the cronies of Saddam Hussein who became
massively wealthy because the the
population suffered as a whole if we if
we stick specifically with dictatorships
and sort of pseudo dictatorships with
authoritarians strong men and and those
types of countries
what are the most effective strategies
for weakening a dictator's Coalition of
supporters like we talked about that the
general population can take what works
what doesn't work
well the the the real problem is
dictators once they're well established
in power they're very very hard to bring
down
so we you need to look for moments of
weakness in bringing about change and we
should recognize that we can't just
bring down dictators because we feel
like getting rid of them you know I
think most people in the United States
would like to see the North Korean
regime replace but that's just wishful
thinking unless the US is willing to
invade which I think would be a very
poor policy uh just expecting that the
people are going to rise up and bring it
down bring the regime down because it's
a terrible regime is not going to happen
right so you need to look for moments of
weakness in regimes and in in autocratic
regime such as North Korea the the times
of actually much more likely to be
health related than any other reason
economic leaders can survive terrible
economic crises we can think of you know
the sanctions in Iraq uh Saddam Hussein
survived those it took U.S military
intervention to remove him we could look
at the Venezuela the Maduro seems to
have held on to power the economy's
being driven into the ground but he made
sure that he paid just the right number
of people just the right amount so they
stayed loyal so the military are well
fed
um and and he survived in power so it's
it we can't just
give instructions to the people and say
this is going to happen you need to that
we should accept that these regimes are
going to survive in power when we look
at
um instances in history where a regime
has fallen uh what are some of the most
notable examples that were not health
related that come to mind
or are there any notable ones that come
to mind well you know
to pay people the right amount of money
and
um harming the interests of those who
keep you in power so you know the
Russians are in World War One
uh he had this crazy
um tax he used to tax vodka but because
he didn't want the troop being drunk he
sort of banned vodka during World War
one that cut off a huge amount of
Revenue cut down on the amount of money
you had to pay people then what did he
do he turned around and told the
soldiers that were guarding him at the
Winter Palace they were going to get
sent to the front line to fight to fight
the Germans well they didn't want to go
fight the Germans at the front line and
what did they do they opened the gates
and allowed the people to come in and
saw the revolution succeeded
generally leaders are deposed because
the people around them allow the masses
to succeed or or they take care of it
and a coup themselves it's very rare
that the people will succeed
um and so that's the case where it's
quite simply the Russians are didn't pay
the right people uh didn't reward them
properly and they turned on him
um the classic case I like to think of
is Julius Caesar so Julius Caesar we
think of as you know if we follow our
Shakespeare we think of him as trying to
be a tyrant well he was already he was
already the dictator he was already
effectively the the king
um the problem for him was he actually
tried to enrich the people
um there was huge debts from the wars
that have been incurred and meant that a
lot of regular Roman citizens were being
sold into slavery because they couldn't
settle their debts and he tried to
alleviate this debt burden unfortunately
the people who own the debt were the
Senators around him so when he tried to
get rid of the debt he tried to help the
people and look what it got him he got
him stabbed by by his fellows in the
Senate
if we go from the autocratic
circumstances and dictators to
democracies one of the features or bugs
depending on your perspective about
democracies uh capitalist democracies
Western democracies is that
um the very nature of the economic
circumstances of large swaths of people
we can think about the United States in
this case is that they are
overwhelmingly in a position where they
can't afford to coalesce and take the
actions that might be most impactful in
in the sense of well Mass rallies at
Urban centers and not going into work
for a month and so on and trying to
the financial system these are
things which we can all imagine having
an impact on the country and at least
having the potential to achieve some
change but because Healthcare is mostly
tied to employment and because 40
percent of the population can't meet an
unexpected 400 expense the system itself
creates a population that will find it
more difficult to activate in a way that
is more likely to achieve change can you
talk a little bit do you agree with that
analysis can you talk a little bit about
whether that does become its own
impediment to activism
well I I think I I actually sort of a
little bit disagree there okay most
Americans don't want to bring down the
American system of government is the
American system of government is
incredibly representative and the
government by and large generates huge
numbers of public goods uh a safe
environment Law and Order transparent
government uh
National Defense
um or all these Public Health these
things are provided and these are
precisely the things people want so we
protest because we would like the
government to work harder but we
actually have a system of government
that we actually like the very few
people seem to want to I mean Trump's
attempt to take over the government the
um yeah
um the relatively few there was
thousands of people who thought that was
a good idea the vast majority of the
people did not show up because they like
the institutions that we have
um you were discussing the inability to
coordinate it's the it's the people who
really want political change who don't
have the ability you and I we have the
right to free speech we can say what we
like we can meet with our friends we can
go where we like we can publish we can
talk we can speak people in North Korea
don't have those freedoms they have a
terrible form of government yes they
live in an abject poverty they're not
allowed to go anywhere they're not
allowed to say anything
um economically they're terribly off
they would love to change their system
of government but they don't have the
ability to in the United States we have
the ability to protest we just you know
the systems the system isn't group isn't
isn't perfect but we shouldn't strive
for Perfection the system is good and
therefore most of the time we don't want
to bring it down well I guess it's
interesting to think about it with
something like for example health care
and when you look at polling about
health care the polling seems pretty
clear that even across the political
Spectrum
people generally believe that the
government should provide some basic
level of care regardless of ability to
pay not everybody supports Medicare for
all very clearly and the more
information you give about Medicare for
all support actually goes down a little
bit but some minimum level of care that
would be something that you would think
is okay we we have a functioning
superstructure but this is a pretty big
program that we would like to see
function differently it doesn't happen
and different people point to different
things well the amount of influence that
the health insurance Lobby has or the
Republican politicians don't want it or
there's too much money to be made for
the doctors under the system we have or
whatever the case may be how would the
type of analysis you do look at
something that is a pretty clear desire
from the people but that doesn't seem to
be getting any closer
well we we should remember that the U.S
whilst it's a good system isn't perfect
and winning winning a seat in Congress
doesn't require like half the voters in
your District first of all the districts
are highly gerrymandered yes many of
them are and so often you just need to
win the primary well we're in the
primary you can often win with five or
ten percent of the votes in the in the
primary so we're really now thinking
that to win a seat to get representation
we're looking at let's say 10 of the
population in of the voting population
in the district well that's much smaller
than thinking about the half that we
tend to think of as Democratic right and
and so if we want to produce changes
that are going to produce more what I
always call public goods things that
benefit everybody good Public Health
Care National Defense things like that
then we want to always work to increase
the number of people to whom politicians
of aholden so you know to win the
presidency and clean up the house and
Senate you only win you need 25 million
votes is enough if you put them in the
right seats because it's not it's it's
first past the post and the seats are
extremely dis unevenly distributed
um and we got the Electoral College so
you don't need you know you sit there I
think it was 360 million people on in
the US so you know let's say there's 200
million so if you need 100 million
voters but you need a quarter of that
because not everybody votes and things
are disproportionately set up so the way
from my perspective the way to think
about improving public policy is to make
leaders accountable to more people the
more people they're interested in the
the smaller the impact of specialist
lobbies like doctors uh Healthcare
lobbyists healthcare insurance companies
um if if you've got to buy you know if
you've got to buy a thousand votes
you're going to listen to them a lot if
you've got to buy a million votes you're
going to listen to them less and so so
to me that is always the the solution to
this is not legislative or anything like
that it's changing the institutions by
which governments operate and I'm trying
to think through the math of like the
congressional district so if you've got
a very lopsided congressional district
let's just call it that there's 750 000
people per congressional district
although it I think it varies a little
bit but let's say it's 7 50.
um if voter turnout in the general is 50
uh but not everybody is even eligible
you're talking about a couple of hundred
thousand total votes but then the
primary might only be a fraction of one
party so you're down to 80 to 100 000
and if only 20 come out that's 20 000
votes and you need 51 of that to win the
primary you're talking about like 12 000
votes might win you a congressional
primary and that might be all there is
to it that's exactly that's exactly the
kind of maths how I like to think about
political systems I don't like to think
of them as in some nominal terms of
democracy accuracy or autocracy or
whatever I like to think of them in
exactly that that's exactly the kind of
calculation I like to think about
classifying political regime so let's
think about how we can change those
things like there are soil loser laws so
if you lose a primary yes you can't run
in the general elections in Six States
right I don't think that that is
everywhere no they vary the rules
because the elect of the Constitution
says the Electoral rules are set by the
by the states but in a lot of places you
can't run again it makes it very hard
um for a Centrist candidate that might
appeal broadly to actually get through
the primary and then run in the general
election so yeah these These are the
kind of changes that I think are useful
for getting implementing Health Care
the book is the dictator's handbook why
bad behavior is almost always good
politics and we've been speaking with
the book's co-author Professor Alastair
Smith from New York University so
appreciate your time and your insights
today
very glad very glad to spend some time
with you
Donald Trump looking as dark orange as
he has ever looked has put out a series
of new statements that are absolutely
chilling in terms of what they mean
regarding freedom of the press freedom
freedom of the justice system the
ability of uh elected officials to be uh
um able to influence prosecution which
is something Trump really wants to do
Trump put out a statement in which he
says he wants the psycho special counsel
investigating him to go after Barack
Obama and Joe Biden Obama why he wants
them to do that isn't completely clear
take a look at this dangerous claim uh
that dangerous statement that Trump is
making Mad Dog psycho prosecutor Jack
Smith
sounds like a very innocent name doesn't
it yeah Jack Smith just so common so so
pedestrian put there for only one reason
by Biden and the weaponized justice
department should stop this Witch Hunt
all together or at a minimum should give
Biden Obama and everybody else he almost
said Obama did you see that he struggled
with it and almost said Obama hunt
all together or at a minimum should give
Biden Obama and everybody else the same
treatment as they give me right now of
course that's really weird that's like
if you're accused of murder and you go
Hey listen you should give my high
school bully the same treatment well but
that is is there reason to think that
the high school bully committed murder
because otherwise why would we do that
doesn't make sense because we have two
sets of Justice in our country that's
true but it's not Democrats and
Republicans it's wealthy Elites versus
everybody else and the people won't
stand for it oh
there you go so a very powerful
declaration from a confused looking
Donald Trump trump also during this
statement and I've not seen him do this
before he positions himself almost like
he's running against both the Democratic
and Republican parties which is very
very interesting and he claims to be
leading both parties it's it's a
confused statement see if you can
understand it
massive and unprecedented
prosecutorial misconduct due to Trump
derangement syndrome and very very big
leads against both parties in the polls
he's leading both parties what what's
causing it we can't let it happen it's
illegal as can be we're going to stop it
we're not going to let them win
elections by using the law illegally
thank you right you can't use the law
illegally and for people wondering this
does seem to be primarily a lighting
issue that is afflicting Trump here I
don't know if antifa is in charge of the
lighting for these videos but Trump says
he's he's leading both parties what does
that even mean this this I struggled to
get through this video without breaking
out an uncontrollable laughter because
it's so so so bizarre Trump also calling
out Reverse Racism in this very same
video which you know again it's it's
either racist or it's not and they
continue to be confused
crooked Democrat prosecutors many of
them racists in Reverse they are
absolute racists in Reverse in Reverse
is being racist in reverse the same as
being the victim of racism maybe that's
what Trump means are trying to steal a
second presidential election are they
they did it in 2020 and we're not going
to let them do it again in 2024. Now
understand what Trump means is I tried
to steal a presidential election in 2024
in 2020 and I am going to try to steal
another one in 2024. that's really what
he means here make America great again
there you go so Donald Trump putting out
these strange there's he's almost like
vlogging they're almost like video blogs
and none of it makes any sense but this
is increasingly the way that Trump
apparently wants to be communicating
with the followers that he has and part
of the advantage I will admit is that
often these videos are done within
little pieces with tons of jump Cuts
it's we've seen behind the scenes video
of Trump trying to record a longer
narrative
and it's very glitchy and it doesn't it
doesn't like go very well for him so
this may be a way that Trump can cut
these things together to make him sound
a little bit more coherent so a really
strange statement and now I want to
focus in more specifically about a
couple other aspects of this very same
speech Donald Trump looks visibly scared
in a new video wherein he demands
cognitive tests for other elected
officials this is completely and totally
Bonkers and what's fascinating is in a
way he's agreeing with Nikki Haley in
that there should be cognitive tests for
elected officials but there is
absolutely seemingly no understanding on
Trump's behalf that many of the people
calling for the tests are calling for
them because they don't think Trump
would pass them let's take a listen to
this in my mind anybody running for the
office of President of the United States
yeah should agree to take a full and
complete mental competence test
simultaneously or before
with the announcement that he or she is
running and likewise but to a somewhat
lesser extent agreed to a test which
would prove that you are physically
capable of doing the job as president
yeah now understand in Trump's mind he
thinks that this full and comprehensive
test would be the Montreal cognitive
assessment where you identify a giraffe
and draw arrows on a clock and remember
five words men woman person camera TV
famously were Trump's examples uh but
that is not a full assessment I hate to
tell you that is like a dementia and
stroke screening brain injury screening
uh anyway let's continue be an
outstanding president requires Great
mental acuity and physical stamina and
strength if you don't have these
qualities or traits it is likely that
you will not succeed and you will
disappoint
the entire world let alone our own
country and that's what happened under
Trump interestingly enough this is like
a very accurate diagnosis of exactly
what happened Trump couldn't do it and
everybody was indeed disappointed we
need to make America great again
take a competency test let's see whether
or not these people that are running for
office are competent I took the test two
years ago and I aced it but I'd love to
take it again because I think I'd even
do better he aced it but he would do
better he would get like X it's like
getting a 4.4 GPA buddy running for
president
we're 350 million people are relying on
you they're relying on your brain
they're relying on your competence
I think taking a competency test would
be a good thing
there you go thank you thank you wow I
just really incredible incredible stuff
and then also really weird when it comes
to videos released by Trump he prays it
he is becoming so obsessed with Ron
DeSantis that he actually in this video
Praises Democrat Charlie Crist and says
Florida's been good from before DeSantis
this is a very interesting approach he's
taking
for those of you that didn't notice
Florida was doing great long before
Rhonda Sanctus got there like I can't
deal with the the Des Sanctus thing I
can't tell if Des Sanctus is that Trump
messed up saying to sanctimonious once
and so now he's he's sticking with the
Sanctus but the serious use of that is
crazy people are fleeing from New York
to Florida and other places right
because of high taxes and out of control
crime it's really bad
not because of the governor thank you Mr
President for doing that but it's not
because of the governor Florida was
doing fantastically you had a governor
named Rick Scott who did a very good job
even Charlie Chris the Democrat did a
good job and he had very good numbers
sunshine and ocean are very alluring
it's not too hard to work it's like a
travel video promo those factors
so just remember Florida was doing
really well long before Iran to Sanctus
got there there you go uh a message from
your president Donald J Trump uh listen
that the one big takeaway there is
for Trump to be willing to praise a
democratic Florida Governor Charlie
Christ he must be really desperate to
attack desanctus in any way possible and
I can only imagine if DeSantis does run
how ugly this is going to get now over
the last 24 hours I received a few
emails from people people in the
audience
who said you know David
I'm actually wondering
is DeSantis setting himself up to run in
2028 because DeSantis May genuinely not
want this ugly primary against Trump
Trump's not going to run in 2028 no
matter what either he'll have been
president for four more years and
that'll be it or he'll lose and he'll be
82 or however old he would be then and
he's not going to run then the way to do
it would be for DeSantis to politely bow
out or does not run and then be ready to
go in 2028 DeSantis would be like 48
years old at the time and that might be
the absolute best way to go it's an
interesting idea it is a quite an
interesting idea I just don't know if
the Santa is going to be able to get
away from the polling numbers that he
has despite the fact that he has he's
not even running yet so we're going to
follow it we will see but Trump highly
highly triggered by desantis's mere
existence in the State of Florida we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P many of you wrote in and
called in and said David
you gotta sue them over that documentary
where they make you seem like a
conspiracy theorist if you don't know
what I'm talking about yesterday I
talked about my inclusion in a
documentary about Malaysia Malaysian
Airlines flight 370 wherein a clip of me
is used that makes me look like a
conspiracy theorist even though in the
clip I'm debunking that conspiracy
theory here's what one caller who says
sue the hell out of them
hey David I just listened to your piece
on the Malaysian flight
um conspiracy theory yeah that you were
on on Netflix
um just a quick comment you absolutely
should sue you should sue those people
took your comments completely out of
context and although you're not inclined
to do so remember that you know this is
how some of these places and people
operate and so there needs to be
consequences
and you I'm sure have the resources to
do it so yeah 100
Sue and uh make them pay all right well
there is one demand that I sue uh I'm
just not very litigious by Nature you
know and it's partially my fault what
happened is I explained but it would be
great content for me to sue so that
would be the one draw to it we'll
explore all right we've got a great
bonus show for you today electric
vehicle stores I guess is what we're
calling them are going to be restricted
in the state of Mississippi Oklahoma
Republicans have voted to let teachers
hit kids with disabilities in school
yeah and South Carolina who get abortion
South Carolina women who get abortions
could face the death penalty under a
proposed new bill yeah it's insane
what's happening all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com you'll get instant
access
foreign